replaying perfect dark i feel like fps
games just aren't made like this anymore
and that's both a positive thing and a
shame at the same time
i think first person shooters have
evolved the most of any genre since
their advent
with battlezone doom and quake
especially on consoles where controls
were always an issue
and somehow rare made it work with the
wonky n64 controller
even if it now feels incredibly dated so
let's take a look back at perfect dark
after goldeneye was released on the n64
and revolutionized fps genre on consoles
people were chomping at the bit for a
sequel so
when rare announced perfect dark a brand
new ip in the style of golden eye
it wasn't what we were expecting as a
quick recap for those of you who aren't
as old as i
hold on my back went out again golden
eye was released in 1997 to the n64
and before that the expectation was that
fps games didn't work on consoles
because of
well controllers like this but goldeneye
blew people away
and was essentially the fortnight of its
time in terms of popularity
the multiplayer was an absolute party
favorite and the game became
iconic so fast forward to 2000 and its
spiritual successor perfect dark
booting up the game you start with
datadyne central and one thing that
immediately stood out is the mission
structure of rare's fps games
you could choose to be either an agent
special agents or perfect
agent and each choice came with more
requirements
and of course much more challenging ai
so if you wanted to enjoy more
objectives you had to get
good but that's part of what made the
game solo campaign so replayable
if you finish the game in special agent
it gave you more incentive to go back
and replay the campaign again
as there would be new objectives i'm not
mentioning agent because
come on who played agent mode okay so
this badass
future of perfect dark with flying cars
takes place in the far
far off future of 2023
and i'd say we're about there with the
cars and weaponry
you're immediately thrust into a cool
infiltration mission where your
objective is to extract dr
carroll and okay now that i'm playing
with the n64 controller it is weird
compared to today
the analog stick moves you forward and
back but also tilts your head
left and right meanwhile the c buttons
move you left and right but then tilt
your head up and down
it's weird because you expect turning to
be the c buttons and moving to be the
analog stick
you can change your controls but you can
never set the analog to be walk and
strafe
meaning you can't mimic modern controls
so
somehow the default feels the most
natural on the n64
and i don't know how many people realize
this but you could actually do a dual
controller setup
it may look ridiculous but now i've got
dual analog
baby now you're playing with power
now you're playing with power and
speaking of power you actually need a
ram expansion pack on the n64 to even
play
well pretty much the entire game and
luckily
donkey kong 64 came with one don't
replay that one
trust me okay so back to datadyne and
the campaign of perfect dark
part of what made the game so cool
compared to many modern fps games
was this mission structure you weren't
just gunning down and shooting enemies
instead you had specific tasks you had
to take care of like disabling security
shooting cameras that might spot you and
even reprogramming cleaning robots
that meant oftentimes you didn't
actually have to murder every single
enemy in your path
you only had to murder every single
enemy in your path sometimes
all of this aided by in retrospect and
now playing the game again
an incredibly forgiving aim assist as
long as your cursor was pointed in the
general vicinity of an enemy
you could count on the imesis to take
charge and start shooting the wrong
enemy who was next to the one you
actually wanted to shoot
and lest i forget as it's a rare n64
game
everybody knows some form of kung fu and
karate chops are an acceptable way to
attack if you don't have a gun
you also have plenty of gadgets similar
to james bond that would help you
accomplish your various tasks
from ecm mines you'd have to place on
security systems to your handy cam spy
you could send out on its own
and more the game was filled with cool
sci-fi tech you'd have to utilize on
your missions
and that's another major theme of
perfect dark the science fiction
elements
dr carroll for example turns out to be
an ai
uh yeah and by that i mean a flying
laptop with flappy robot wings
and who could forget the major reveal of
perfect dark when you first find
elvis the alien who's part of a race
trying to protect humanity from an
evil alien race the plot is off the
walls and continuously brings in more
and more insane weapons with the
combination of advanced human technology
and alien weaponry
what that meant was some super creative
choices that made both the solo campaign
and multiplayer an absolute blast to
play
there was of course the laptop gun this
iconic weapon looks just like a general
laptop but also has a mode that
transforms it into a submachine gun
and even better you could also deploy it
as a century gun turret
making it one of the better weapons of
the game and who could forget the
farsight
xr20 which combines an x-ray with a gun
that can literally
shoot through walls it even had a
secondary mode that tracked its targets
and those are just some of the cool
aspects of these weapons compared to
goldeneye
most weapons had two modes and while
some were better than others with
joanna's handy falcon 2
only having a pistol whip as its
secondary mode it was exciting picking
up a new gun
and discovering all of its unique
capabilities even the music of the game
is
badass and i unashamedly will listen to
the ost
from the game when i wanted a break
major shout out to airbase espionage x
that song is mwah chef's kiss good
also as a former resident i have a soft
spot for both the fact you end up in
chicago during the course of the
campaign and the song itself
chicago which looks uh
yeah that's pretty much what i remember
chicago looking like there's plenty to
love about perfect dark that i think is
now often considered bad game design
oftentimes you'll find yourself
backtracking or a little confused about
how to tackle a mission objective
there is a mission briefing you can read
at any point that will hint you in the
right direction
but it's not always fully clear and
honestly
even in replaying the game i kind of
like that the game actually trusts you
to experiment and figure things out
and sometimes you will fail and not just
because you got shot in the face
alright a lot of times because you got
shot in the face
but sometimes it was because you
couldn't quite figure out how to do an
objective
and i kind of dig that the game just
lets you fail and try again
and beyond that another thing i just
love about perfect dark are the cheats
you can unlock
it was an error where you didn't need to
purchase add-ons in dlc
so developers are really pushed to make
their games as replayable as possible
with cheese being just one of those
incentives and perfect dark handled this
in the
well perfect way with cheats being
something you unlock by completing
missions
often times within a certain amount of
time and on a certain difficulty
that meant you had a strong incentive to
replay a level over
and over and over and over
again until you finally mastered it and
unlocked the psychosis gun
which is yet another amazing and
creative weapon that made enemy ai fight
against their own teammates
in december 2020 a new perfect dark was
announced at the game awards which is
being developed by a new microsoft
studio called the initiative
and while perfect r0 was definitely not
the sequel anybody wanted
i like to hope that the new perfect dark
is something that stays true to the
original
while modernizing its controls and
handling i think if it can tap into the
creativity
and mission structure of the original
game then we'll have something truly
fantastic to look forward to and who
doesn't want a brand new perfect dark
multiplayer
just stop looking at my screen dammit i
know you were screen looking
don't try to deny it what are some of
your favorite memories playing perfect
dark and are you looking forward to the
sequel
let us know in the comments below and
i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you